sammarinese benvenuti li nuovissimo b
oggi parliamo di make up come l'anno
scorso ho voluto fare un video facendomi
vedere due trucchi secondo me molto
carini per le feste perinatale
in particolare ho deciso di fare il
tutorial di due make up uno un po più
semplice un po più soft che quello che
vedete addosso ma in questo momento
molto facile da realizzare uno un pelino
più sofisticate un po meno sobrio un po
più marina è un po più carico quindi
anche leggermente più complicato da
realizzare
partiamo subito con il primo make up
quello soft per questo make up ho
utilizzato la palette poison garden di
nabla iniziamo subito stendendo zen su
l'angolo esterno dell'occhio poi
enfatizziamo ulteriormente lo sguardo
con opera esponiamo bene infine
applichiamo rosita con il paul pastello
sulla palpebra mobile
sulla rima ciliare inferiore con un
pennellino sono andata ad applicare
sempre opera e poi anche una matita
rosso scuro in particolare utilizzato
dai soldi knicks nell'angolo interno per
illuminare lo sguardo applicato
adoration poi ho colorato la rima
ciliare superiore con una matita marrone
sempre dx
ho applicato il mascara e infine sulle
labbra o applicato un lipgloss sempre di
nabla che si chiama crazy diamond e
vuole e dopo un trucco soffrissimo
passiamo un trucco tutt'altro che sobrio
perché come potete notare gigliati inter
rossetto bello intenso e carico quindi
sicuramente un make up più sofisticato
più aggressivi marina partiamo subito
con into tory al per questo make up
invece utilizzato iconica
in particolare ho iniziato stendendo
marilyn su l'angolo esterno dell'occhio
o sfumato bene e poi ho applicato cocco
sempre sull'angolo esterno con un
pennellino stesso sempre cocco anche
sulla rima ciliare inferiore poi con il
polpastrello ho applicato grace sulla
palpebra mobile il nostro amatissimo
eyeliner sempre presente
ho applicato il mascara sia sopra che
sotto
il super illuminante di farsa lì le
ciglia finte e poi sono passata alle
labbra
ho disegnato prima il contorno e poi
applicato ciocco red di clio un bel po
di cipria fissante la terra
et voilà
[Musica]
siamo arrivati purtroppo alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che vi siano
piaciuti questi due make up che ho
scelto per voi e che chissà magari vi
possiate utilizzare per le vostre di
natale per i vostri pranzi di natale per
le vostre feste ecco fatemi sapere con
un commento qui sotto quale dei due make
up avete preferito e come al solito se
non l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
canale e cliccate sulla campanella che
trovate vicino al tasso di iscrizione
per ricevere una notifica a tutte le
volte che pubblico nuovi video e mi
raccomando selezionate tutte le
notifiche
seguitemi anche su tutti gli altri
social facebook instagram e tic toc ho
pubblicato anche ultimamente dei tic toc
di make up diciamo quindi seguitemi
anche lì e vi mando un bacione norme ci
vediamo al prossimo video ciao d'oro
[Musica]